[Music]
thank you for coming to my talk thank
you for coming to this stage this stage
don't tell anybody but this is the
actual better stage so come back and
hang out over here later you might see
me around my talk is going to be titled
full stack development in the era of
several is computing and I'm gonna be
doing something today that I've never
actually done before and I've been
working pretty hard on an open source
project for the last few months and I
think right here at the end of the day
at the end of this talk we're gonna go
ahead and release that and we're gonna
go ahead and publish that live on stage
so I'm pretty excited about that so my
name is Nader dabit I'm a mobile and web
developer really been specializing in
cross-platform development for the last
couple of years mainly really focused
with react native so if you've ever
listened to react native radio up a host
of that podcast for a couple of years
I'm very active in the react Native
community and more so kind of like
pivoting now towards full stack
development with cloud computing but I'm
still doing a lot in the cross-platform
world world you can follow me on Twitter
dev to medium github everywhere on
social media I'm at dabit 3 so I've
written a couple of books the book that
I've working on right now it's called
full stack serverless
touches on a lot of the topics that
we're gonna be covering today it really
focuses mainly on the combination of ake
a client a front-end it doesn't have to
be react I'm using react in the book but
it's kind of more around the building of
full stack applications levering the
cloud leveraging the cloud using some of
the more modern tooling and I using
graph QL and in my book I'm using Apple
and AWS and AWS amplify on the team that
I work on is the AWS client technologies
team when people think of Amazon has on
Web Services they typically think of
backends they think of ec2 instances
storage they don't really think of
front-end development but the entire
team that I work on were always entirely
focused on actually building for
front-end developers we talked to
funding developers we are front-end
developers we live and breathe the
front-end ecosystem so everything that
we do is really focused around
improving the developer experience and
really what we're trying to do is kind
of enable the next generation of
developers to start leveraging the cloud
because in the past the big cloud
computing has been a little inaccessible
because it's just really hard to get
kind of get started unless you're
already familiar with it so just on my
personal note something that's really
served me well as being a futurist and
this may sound stupid and I'm eight you
may think it's cool whatever but really
the idea of being a futurist is less
about predicting the future and I think
it's more about listening to what's
going on observing the present and
really trying to see what's going to be
happening over the next couple of years
and being at the right place at the
right time so you can ride these waves
when innovation happens you want to be
on the forefront of that innovation so
when the innovation starts cresting you
are in that arena already maybe you're
specializing in that thing already so
you can kind of like gain the benefit
from that and maybe reach back and help
others as well so the definition of my
talk is kind of along these lines and
this is the answer or the question I
want to answer today is what does
full-stack mean in the era of several s
computing and we're gonna look at why I
use the word era in just a moment and to
start this off I really like this quote
from Bill Gates I choose a lazy person
to do a hard job because a lazy person
will find an easy way to do it
I don't think he means lazy in the sense
of sitting at home sleeping late
watching Spongebob and not going to work
I think what he means is lazy in the
sense that I'm not going to do something
if someone else has already done it or
maybe I'm gonna find some abstraction
that makes this thing the end goal more
easy to accomplish versus reinventing
the wheel or just being efficient with
with things in general I think it's kind
of in my opinion where where he's what
he's saying there and this kind of
starts off in our world with
abstractions and there are two main
parts of this talk front end and back
end so look at let's look at the front
end abstractions and see what's happened
over the last couple of years so if
you're new into front-end development
you may not have known this but back in
the day you could actually get a pretty
good job as a friendly developer knowing
the basics of HTML see
maybe jQuery maybe you didn't even know
jQuery you just knew JavaScript and you
knew how to manipulate the Dom using
JavaScript and you could get by with not
really much more knowledge than that but
today it's not the same world that we
live in is it and the complexity on the
front-end is gaining momentum right
we're getting good abstractions but as
these abstractions come people are
introducing new problems to solve and
therefore we need to have ways to solve
them so therefore people are gonna build
things for us to solve these problems
and therefore tooling and new things
come out so what we end up with is all
of this stuff that we think that we need
to know and that we may need to know
some of this stuff to get a job these
days right so the complexity on the
front end is moving much more faster to
being more complex lately and people
when they used to think of front-end
developers they used to think of
front-end developers is kind of like not
that serious developers but now we're
being taken more seriously because
anyone kind of coming into this
ecosystem must be taken seriously and
really the reasons I think a lot of this
really comes down to or these you know
main areas here so single page
applications make us structure our
applications in different ways our data
is becoming more complex and we're
having to deal with a lot more data
microservices make the fetching of data
a little more complex we're dealing with
multiple targets we don't really only
want to ship to a single device these
days we have all these new devices that
we're working with and then the the user
expectations that people get from you
know being used to maybe using some of
the more modern applications you want
your application to meet those needs so
you end up trying to have an application
that you know kind of does all these
things and leads to your users
expectations so where are some of the
abstractions that we're seeing that are
kind of making this a little bit easier
there's a bunch out there but what we're
seeing things like manage graph QL like
asura and 1/8 base style components or a
motion for CSS and j/s and it's kind of
like a hybrid of CSS and CSS and yes you
know the next Jack's with gatsby react
native for a cross platform so
as things become more complex we're
seeing abstractions that kind of make
these easier now what about the back end
who here is a considers themself a
back-end developer okay so that's kind
of what I assumed with this conference
because I'm a front-end developer I
assumed that this was a front-end
comprehend sand that's kind of what you
know this that just told me so let's
talk about the backend and this is just
a quick overview of maybe a similar
timeframe of 10 years or 20 years or so
so a long time ago when you built an
application and you needed to host it
somewhere you may have had it on
premises you may have had your server in
your home or in your office if the
internet went out or if there was a
storm and the power went out there was
all these different variables that were
up to you know the gods I guess you
could say that to you know whether or
not your application was gonna stay up
and that was kind of you know where you
were at at that point and then we had
cloud computing that started coming
along and the cloud computing could be
you know mentioned as AWS and Microsoft
and all these things but it's also all
these hosting services right because
you're kind of moving your
infrastructure into these hosting
services and they're kind of taking care
of most most of the dealing with the
scaling
I'm sorry off the scaling but dealing
with the hardware and dealing with the
hardware maintenance and then we had
several lists so server list has been
kind of this new thing over the last
five or so years and we're gonna dive
pretty deep into this and the main
advantage that turbo lists Brinks the
table over cloud is that instead of
having to not only deal with keeping
your you know servers up and running and
keeping everything working you now also
don't have to deal with scaling or
patching or maintaining your servers at
all you're just given invitations
functions that you can run and then once
that functions done being run you don't
have to worry about dealing with it you
also don't have to worry about scaling
this so if you end up with one user or a
million users that several assumptions
will scale for you you're also starting
to pay for computing time versus
computing power so when you're dealing
with the basic cloud infrastructure
managing your own instances of ec2 may
be you might be paying for that server
regardless if someone's using it when
you start moving into the service
paradigm you're now paying for the
actual usage so this means you can start
building a lot and were things without
spending a lot of money out of your
pocket once you get users then you start
paying which is you know a better
problem to have so what comes next after
service and this is what really
interests me because I think we're
starting to see this happen already and
I don't really know what exactly it is
I'm just gonna give you my opinion of
what it is so let's talk about the
definition of what services and a little
more depth what I really am interested
in sometimes is these scientific and you
know papers that come out from different
you know colleges and all of these
different really academic research done
on several lists and cloud computing in
general a really interesting one that
came out was cloud computing simplified
a Berkley view on service computing and
the gist of what this paper said is this
while cloud functions package that's
functions as a service offerings so
functions as a service would be service
functions while these represent the core
of serverless computing cloud platforms
are also specialized service free also
provides specialized service frameworks
that cater to specific application
requirements as backends as a service so
basically what they're saying put simply
service computing is equal to functions
as a service and backends as a service
so this is a mutation of the old
definition of service where several is
used to mean service functions now
they're starting to group other things
into this into this paradigm so what
they're saying now is okay not only are
we talking about service functions we're
talking about kind of managed services
or backends as a service so I went to
the end of the paper and they have a
predictions area so these are the
predictions that they have at the end of
the paper pretty interesting they think
and then in the future you're gonna see
more back end as a service storage off
offerings server list becomes simpler
even more simple than it is today
service ultimately becomes cheaper than
server full which is super interesting
in my opinion which would really change
a lot of things than the in the world I
think of what it is today
servo server full computing becomes less
important relatively which makes a lot
of sense but the most important
point was that they came at the end was
this serverless competing becomes the
default computing paradigm of the cloud
area so we're moving to to where
serverless is going to be the default
versus something else being the default
which is pretty interesting to me
another definition comes from Ben Keogh
and instead of saying serverless is a
thing he says service is more of a
spectrum or a variance and Ben Kehoe is
a engineering lead leader or manager at
iRobot and they make the Roomba robot
and he's running a server list
infrastructure there and to be more
servile as he says that you have to be
more server service full and I'll talk
about what that means in just a moment
and using functions as a service a
tighter correspondence between resources
use and resources build again going back
to paying for compute time versus
compute power and then smaller and more
abstracted control plane so what is
service full mean so service full means
this this is kind of what I've put
together based on some of the research
that I've done so what is the service
full service service full service has no
server operations it scales seamlessly
no need to manage up Tom and variable
expense versus victus fixed expense so
we're kind of inheriting these four
properties from server lists but we're
adding a couple of new ones we're also
saying that a service full service to be
considered service full also it needs to
be essentially codeless so codeless in
the sense that we don't have to deal
with the code not that there isn't any
code running in the background
we're just interacting with these api's
and then also this service will assume
responsibility prefer providing a
defined set of services so that means
we're kind of taking you know what
they're giving us and we're just using
with what they're offering and these are
a few examples alt 0 is really great for
managed authentication I'll go Lea is
really great for search cloud in area
for storage you have recognition for
machine learning and net low fee and app
sync you have all these things coming
out there hundreds or even thousands of
these right and you're seeing more and
more of these so how does graph QL fit
into this because I think it really does
play a very important role well as the
the end goal of what
I think is happening with all this
server several is computing is it's
making everything more efficient it's
making us be able to build things
quicker our developer velocity is moving
faster we're able to experiment more
often and without as many drawbacks so
if we know that we're not gonna pay for
this actual computing power we know that
we can build something really quickly
and we know that that's not gonna cost
us a lot of money why not try building
this thing out in the next couple of
days and just seeing if it works because
our investment is continually going down
even if the sink fails we're able to at
least try it out so on that idea of
developer velocity I think graph QL
brings that developer velocity to the
table as well with building your own
graph QL server though you're losing
some of that velocity because it's
actually not easy to implement a graph
QL server with the proper authentication
and authorization rules and all of the
stuff that goes along with that right
but anyway so let's talk about graph QL
and why this is the case so a typical
micro service architecture might look
something like this you might be
interacting directly with the micro
service or you might have some type of
API gateway where you have that single
API endpoint and you're interacting
through that API gateway with graph QL
you have a similar end goal right but
instead of just having all these random
you know implementations of the API you
now have a unified way of interacting
with that data so no matter what happens
after the request goes through when you
query data you send that query from the
client the exact same way and regardless
of the actual implementation details on
the server you're still going to be
getting the data back the same way on
the client so you don't have to worry
about any of the implementation details
on the back end you're given all this
also in a menu so with graph QL you have
introspection you can see all the
different operations available you can
see all of the data that's available you
know exactly the data that's coming back
it makes for much much better user
experience once once it's actually there
right but getting there I think is the
hard part and that's that's another
thing that I want to kind of talk about
a little more and this brings what I
call schema centric development the
unified data graph the front and the
back ended up being closer and more in
sync you end up having type safe
throughout you have simple access to
data per client so you can also be
thinking about this in the sense that
you're gonna be needing this same data
from your mobile device from the desktop
device and maybe from your Apple watch
but you don't want to be bringing the
same data down on these different
devices you're gonna need different
types of data graph QL is perfect for
that
consistent API to microservices lambda
functions and databases so you end up
using graph QL as an API gateway to all
these other micro services that are
still there you're not getting rid of
them you're just actually putting them
in front of graph QL so full stack
server lists this is something that I
really am really interested in and I
think that I'm gonna be giving you my
spiel of what it is so full stack server
list has the following characteristics
having an intentional use of managed
services you choose a managed service
because you don't want to rewrite
something that someone else has done
right so you you have a feature you
first look to see if there's some type
of managed service that can accomplish
that goal no ok next we go and we fund
and we build our own function that does
the thing that we want it to do even
better if we have some custom client
SDKs that make our API interactions
easier so we don't want to have a lot of
I guess custom code that we're creating
to interact with all these different API
s if you're using something like Apollo
for example this kind of falls into that
category where we have this custom SDK
for graph QL and we're able to use this
for all the different operations that
we'd like to use and then graph QL as
the main data source is up in a part and
port of this important part of this so
what are some assumptions and
acknowledgments around full stack
service well you assume that code is a
liability in the least code that you can
write the better so anytime that you can
get away with not writing code you do it
the front end skill set continues to
become increasingly valuable and I think
we're gonna continue to see this in the
future we've already seen the
skyrocketing you know value of front-end
developers the skyrocketing money that
people are getting paid these days to be
a front-end developer I think that's not
gonna stop and it's going to continue
going up deliberate focus on not
reinventing the wheel so if someone else
has done it we're going to use what they
have done
to save our time to save us some time
and with our increased value as
developers the least time that we spent
right doing something anyway the better
because we're gonna be saving time and
therefore money and then what really
interests me is the definition of
front-end back-end DevOps full-stack all
this starts to blur because as a
front-end developer if you understand
how to work with these api's you're able
to do all these things that these other
people used to do but you don't maybe
need them anymore to do all this other
stuff maybe you still need them to do
certain things but for the most part you
don't need someone creating all of these
cruddy a P is on the backend because you
can spin those up with some type of
managed database you don't need someone
to create your authentication on the
backend because you're gonna use an
authentication service and all these
other things that kind of go into that
and then the DevOps part with several
this kind of goes away so what are the
benefits well the benefits might be you
know pretty straightforward I may have
gone over some of these already but what
we're seeing now is front-end developers
that used to be stable Daz front-end
developers are now being called full
stack developers or they're at least
moving up the stack they're able to do
things that back-end developers only
exclusively used to do the developer
velocity developer efficiency starts
increasing you have decreased complexity
because you have ultimately less code
more secure more reliable more scalable
why would this be more secure and more
reliable well think about it if you are
a front-end developer and you want to
create an authentication service and
you've never done this before you spend
three weeks doing it you know do you
think you've done a better job than
someone who's worked on an
authentication service for 12 years or
five years or even two years that person
and that team has iterated and solved
all these problems unknown unknowns that
you might not even know about so of
course in my opinion that's gonna be
more secure than spinning something up
yourself so how can we get into this
well I'm gonna talk about some tools
that are out there and kind of demo some
stuff that I'm working on so the
combination of these four things equals
full stack server lists so a web and
mobile framework or web or mobile
framework and you as a web or funding
developer utilize service functions
graph QL and managed services to build
your applications so what are some tools
out there so for managed services all
zero cloud Andheri algo Leonel fi
serverless graph QL more options coming
out eight base recently came out really
nice basura Kosmos DB has a an adapter
and apps acres but we work on several is
functions natla fine now do I even have
to go into this list there dozens of
them out there in fact every week or
every month I see a new provider coming
out with a abstraction over serverless
functions now what do I work on the team
that I work on we're building a
framework especially for this so we call
this AWS amplify has the four things
that I have listed here we have a
command line that creates manage
services
we have a client that connects to the
services we have hosting provider for CI
and CD and then we have a tool chain for
doing things like graph QL cogent what
are some of the things that you can do
well authentication graph ul api's
service functions of api's storage ai
machine-learning hosting AR and VR I
have a bunch of stuff not listed here
but you can go check it out on our
website we also have framework specific
components for all of the major
front-end library's react react native
view angular ionic and what's my
favorite thing about what we're working
on is this graph QL transform library
and this is essentially an STL over
regular graph QL schema that allows you
to decorate your schema and add
additional features and what these
features and what ends up happening
under the hood is we create those
resolvers for you and then you can then
modify your resolvers with your own
business logic so if you need a database
schema subscriptions resolvers for a
crud app and you you wanted to make it a
to-do app instead of writing create read
update delete to do operations the
resolvers the database having all that
created you can just create a to-do type
decorate it with the add model will
deploy the database will create all that
schema you can then just modify that to
you know work on your app we have all
these other ones all for adding
authorization rules connection for
adding data relationships one-to-many
many-to-many all this other stuff as
well so what about a several for the
server list backends yeah I think this
is basically the the stuff I kind of
whenever already
what you end up with when you use the
graphic you all transform you have
authorization rules on your API you end
up with your database and all this other
stuff and to get started with this you
just run amplify a net amplify add off
and then you choose graph QL and you're
kind of ready to go now for the demos so
what I want to demo first
is I want to show you can we build a
confidence app for the reactive conf in
the next two minutes yeah two minutes
why not so what I created was confidence
app in a box and this is an
implementation of full stack serverless
what we have here is the react native
app that you get out of the box once you
create a new go ahead and see if I can
refresh this
all right there we go so conference up
in a box yeah I created its open-source
project if you want to create a
conference app you clone it run amplify
a net and then you can DUP populate the
database so this is what the boilerplate
comes out to let's create the app for
this conference so what I want to do is
first go ahead and open up some text
editor and what we're going to do is I'm
going to go ahead and get the
information that we're going to need for
this conference so first of all we need
to get some conference speakers so what
I want to do is populate the database so
to do that I'm going to go into the
amplify console and what we're going to
do is create a couple of talks so the
first talk I'm going to create is going
to be guest this talk and then I'll go
ahead and create this talk here I think
two talks is enough let's go ahead and
refresh all right we see that we have
our our speakers they're populated we
can drill down we can see the
information that we populated this with
next let's go ahead and theme this
because this doesn't really look like
the reactive color scheme so what we
want to do is set a base primary and
light primary colors so I'm going to go
into the theme I'll go ahead and update
that I'll update the highlight color and
we're gonna do is then update the logo
over yeah okay cool things what we're
gonna do for the logo is we're going to
use this reactive logo so let's go ahead
and refresh that and now we have a
reactive comp app well that looks very
similar actually because the color
scheme is similar but now you see we
have green let's go ahead and add a
comment though because maybe we want to
troll somebody and tell them that their
talk is not good so what you can do is
you can create a comment and this will
be gone well this will be done through
graphical
subscriptions so we'll come through in
real time so let's go ahead and list
talks first and we get the talk ID for
the talk we want to create a comment for
so now we'll go ahead and get the
mutation for creating a comments and
I'll take this talk ID and I'll put it
here and then you see that the talk came
in in real time we have our you know
comments coming through all this was
deployed within about five minutes using
the full stack front-end and back-end so
that's one thing I'm working on the next
thing I want to show off is something
I'm that I am releasing today so this is
the jam stack CMS and I'm gonna go ahead
and pull my slide deck back up so I can
kind of give you an overview as you can
see I speak at a bunch of conferences so
where were we oh yeah so conference up
in a box so one last thing I've worked
with over 30 conferences with that I've
only been out it's only about for about
six months I've worked with three
independent consultants for that that
have sold their app reskin there for
$50,000 total and the average hourly
rate was one thousand and five hundred
dollars because they all they did was
like download this app and resell it for
like fifteen to twenty thousand dollars
pretty cool
so based on my pricing that the 30
conferences that I've worked with it's
around half a million dollars in value
that I've got that people have gotten
from it so far and it's completely free
and open source and then today I'm
introducing this the gem stacks EMS jam
stacks CMS is a full stack CMS built
with Gatsby
on the front end it's built with several
s technologies on the back end and you
can deploy to any hosting provider net
laugh i amplify console with a single
click using web hooks um this is kind of
an overview of what it looks like and
let's go ahead and tend kind of take a
look at how it works real quick so this
is the this is kind of a running version
of a full stack so CMS thing that I've
deployed recently this is essentially
you know my opinion it's like a modern
version of WordPress because when you
think of WordPress WordPress has the
database the authentication the
front-end the everything all kind of
bundled into one this is the same thing
but kind of built with modern
technologies you can create posts you
can create pages and the admin panel you
can kind of see all the posts that
you've created you can unpublish
directly from the admin panel you can
create a new post using the the WYSIWYG
editor you can actually create new web
pages as well and once you have you know
figured out where you want everything to
go you just go ahead and click Save or
publish and it will go ahead and publish
there's also a settings where you can
change the theme that you'd like to be
working with so maybe we want to have
this reactive comp theme we can set that
and then once we're ready to kick off a
new build we can actually just click
deploy and this will deploy a new
version of our app into our hosting
provider and for me I'm using amplify
console so if I go here look at Jam SEC
CMS I'll give this a second I come back
and it's still not building it there we
go so now we see that we've kicked off a
new build we did that directly from the
front end the the thing that's happening
is we're building and deploying those
static assets so when people access this
site and they're not an admin they just
see the blog okay so that's it I'm sure
I'm a little bit over on time we'll go
ahead and wrap this up if you want to
follow Jam stack CMS oh you know what I
said I was going to release this lava
land stage let's go ahead and do that so
my go-to settings and my github repo Jam
stack CMS make public
first time I've ever done that so go if
you if you're watching this go star this
and and like brag about it and all that
stuff and tell all your friends okay
cool yeah so thank you for listening to
my talk I'm gonna skip my last few
slides but thank you for listening my
talk
[Applause]
[Music]